well when you think vintage vegas a
video game store may not be the first
place that comes to mind but chances are
good you haven't been to game repair
photojournalist chad graves opens the
doors and takes us inside
it's a cool store it's like you see so
many vintage games
so many new games and it was just one of
those things where it's like
it's a piece of history and it kind of
just stays here playstation 3
playstation 4 we have even some of these
old vintage
systems that were before my time
but i've been coming here since i was
seven years old we used to live across
the next door in the apartments
and we would always you know jump the
wall and be like hey we're going to get
repair we would just come in here
and look at all the video games that
they had i love
talking to customers helping people my
brother actually
um is now a graphic designer for
petroglyph games
because he you know we got into video
games at such a young age
and it was just amazing like this place
was home to us always so every time we
would come in
they would always treat us right and
just made us feel welcome my clientele
base is the best
you know they just they know what
they're here for
in my opinion i think it's brian because
he's the one who
makes the people feel welcome at this
shop he doesn't
he does he gives you the good
suggestions he tells you like hey you
know try this game
this game is really good and it's just
just the atmosphere itself
how he he just makes everybody feel
welcome i've been blessed and i'm
grateful and i thank you to all my
customers that have
been with me for all these years it's
been the
greatest ride of all
thank you